bonjour
aujourd'hui on va parler
et d'edward bernays ce dernier était un
un américain né en autriche il est mort
en 1995 à l'âge de 103 ans aux côtes en
dire qu'il a traversé tout le xxème
siècle et berna il est considéré comme
le père fondateur de la propagande
politique et industriel moderne
il a mis au point deux célèbres
techniques de manipulation de l'opinion
des techniques qui l'a décrite dans l'un
de ses ouvrages les plus connus
propagande a sous titré comment
manipuler l'opinion en démocratie et si
vous êtes du genre à combattre le
complotisme et bien bernard risque de
vous mettre dans l'embarras parce que
voilà un homme qui fait partie de la
grande machine du pouvoir économique et
qui fournit littéralement le mode
d'emploi de la domination idéologique et
de la manipulation de l'opinion en
démocratie
j'oserais même un parallèle en disant
que vers nice c'est un petit peu le
maquis avait dû xxème siècle de la même
façon que machiavel conseiller le prince
sur la meilleure manière de manipuler le
peuple et de l'influencé via la même
façon darnaise conseiller les hommes
politiques et les grands industriels et
leur expliquer comment faire pour
augmenter leur capital que ce soit leur
capitale économique où leur capital
symbolique et on sait qu'en politique le
capital symbolique c'est à dire la
confiance la sympathie le crédit sont
des promesses de chiffre d'affaires sont
des promesses de résultats électoraux
et la particularité de bernès à l'image
de machiavel
c'est qu'il ne se cache pas
c'est qu'il assume sa démarche
assume d'autant plus facilement que pour
lui la démocratie c'est d'abord un
régime dans lequel une minorité éclairée
minorité intelligente doit modeler
l'opinion publique pour le bien de la
société
voilà ce qu'écrit bernès dans son livre
je cite la manipulation consciente et
intelligente des actions et des opinions
des masses est un élément important dans
une société démocratique
ceux qui manipulent ce mécanisme
invisible de la société constitue un
gouvernement invisible qui est le vrai
pouvoir dans notre pays nous sommes
gouvernés nos esprits sont formés nos
goûts éduquer nos idées suggérées en
grande partie par des hommes dont nous
n'avons jamais entendu parler
vous voyez qu avec burns on n'est pas
pris en traître
il annonce clairement la couleur et si
on devait résumer très brièvement le
postulat de départ de bernard
il s'agit d'un postulat psychologique
qui consiste à dire qu'une foule est
d'abord régi par ses instincts parce que
freud appelait le ca c'est à dire
concrètement par ses pulsions
contrairement à ce que nous pourrions
croire naïvement la démocratie ne serait
pas le lieu du pouvoir du peuple
d'ailleurs l'idée même de pouvoir du
peuple résonne ici comme une antithèse
puisque si le peuple n'obéit qu'à ses
instincts il n'obéit pas à ses intérêts
il n'obéit pas sa raison donc la
démocratie n'est pas le lieu du pouvoir
du peuple la démocratie c'est le régime
dans lequel on manipule l'opinion du
peuple au lieu de le contraindre
c'est en ce sens qu'on peut dire qu'une
démocratie c'est une dictature matures
c'est une dictature abouti puisque c'est
un régime dans lequel on va chercher à
influencer plutôt qu'à imposer
il est vrai que lorsqu'on impose aux
peuples trop de choses qu'il refuse
lorsqu'on lui impose trop de choses qui
ne vont pas dans le sens de ses intérêts
le risque c'est celui de la révolte
voire de la révolution parce qu'un
peuple que l'on contraint c'est un
peuple qui ne peut que se rendre compte
qu'il est contraint
c'est un peuple qui a conscience d'être
sous l'emprise d'un pouvoir tyrannique
et lorsque le pouvoir est visible
lorsqu'il apparaît à ses victimes de
manière consciente et bien ce n'est plus
qu'une question de temps avant que le
peuple ne se rebelle
ce n'est plus qu'une question de temps
avant que le peuple ne cherche à faire
valoir ses droits
alors que dans une société démocratique
c'est-à-dire dans une société où
l'opinion du peuple n'est pas contrainte
mais influencer le peuple a l'impression
de garder la main sur ses opinions
il al'impression de garder la main sur
sa liberté
eh bien on va voir aujourd'hui en quoi
l'art de la propagande d'edward bernays
permet justement de maintenir le peuple
dans la domination sans que ce peuple ne
soient conscients d'être manipulés
ce qui veut dire que pour comprendre la
pensée de bernès il va falloir
abandonner nos croyances angélistes sur
la démocratie et accepter l'idée que
ceux qui détiennent le pouvoir ne
travaille pas pour les intérêts du
peuple mais pour leur propre intérêt
alors petite information entre
parenthèses il se trouve que bernard est
le neveu de sigmund freud dont il s'est
beaucoup inspiré et notamment sur
l'importance de l'inconscient et du
subconscient dans nos choix on sait que
pour freud à grande majorité de notre
vie psychique est gouvernée par notre
inconscient c'est à dire par nos désir
pulsionnel et notre vie consciente n'est
que la pointe émergée de l'iceberg n'est
que la surface visible de notre activité
psychique
car en réalité nos désirs et nos pensées
sont grande majorité gouverné par nos
désirs inconscients
à ce propos voici ce qu'écrit burns je
cite les psychologues de l'école de
freud ont montré que nos pensées et nos
actions sont des substituts
compensatoire de désir que nous avons dû
refouler
autrement dit il nous arrive de désiré
telle chose non parce qu'elle est
intrinsèquement précieuses ou utile mais
parce que inconsciemment nous y voyons
un symbole d'autres choses dont nous
n'osons pas nous avouer que nous le
désirons un homme qui achète une voiture
se dit probablement qu'il en a besoin
pour se déplacer alors qu'au fond lui il
préférait peut-être ne pas s'encombrer
de cet objet et c'est qu'il vaut mieux
marcher pour rester en bonne santé sont
en vie tient vraisemblablement au fait
que la voiture est aussi un symbole du
statut social une preuve de la réussite
en affaires une façon de complaire à sa
femme
ce grand principe voulant que nos actes
soient très largement déterminée par des
mobiles que nous nous dissimulons vaut
autant pour la psychologie collective
que pour la psychologie individuelle le
propagandiste soucieux de réussir doit
donc comprendre ces mobiles cachés sans
se satisfaire des raisons que les
individus avance pour justifier leur
comportement
donc burns a été influencé par freud il
a également été influencée par gustave
lebon et notamment sa théorie sur la
psychologie des foules et tout le
travail de bernex ge a consisté à mettre
ses connaissances sur la psychologie
sociale ses connaissances sur le
comportement des foules au service des
hommes politiques et des grands
industriels afin de leur permettre
d'étendre leur pouvoir d'étendre leur
influence et ainsi de faire fonctionner
les rouages de la démocratie
alors avant d'aller plus loin je vais
vous proposer un petit florilège des
performances de burns
on va commencer par l'un de ses premiers
faits d'armes c'était en 1910 est en
pleine première guerre mondiale en
europe bernès a aidé le président wilson
à préparer l'opinion publique américaine
à une entrée en guerre et d'ailleurs
c'est à ce moment là qu'a été créée la
célèbre affiche que vous avez tous déjà
vu passer la fiche représentant l'oncle
sam avec cette phrase i want you et qui
a permis aux américains de sortir de
leur pacifisme qui était alors l'opinion
dominante et de justifier l'entrée des
états unis auprès des forces alliées
quelques années plus tard bernese a
lancé une campagne commerciale financé
par l'industrie agroalimentaire pour
promouvoir un petit déjeuner copieux sur
la base de recommandations de médecins
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que vers
nice a commandé une étude auprès de
médecins spécialisés dans la nutrition
pour vanter les vertus d'un petit
déjeuner copieux
du point de vue de la santé il a ensuite
transmis les résultats de cette étude à
la presse qui en a fait ses gros titres
donc à partir de là les ventes de bacon
ont explosé puisque une information
parue dans la presse est soutenu par
4000 médecins
autrement dit soutenu par l'autorité
scientifique ne pouvait que convaincre
les américains de suivre ces nouvelles
recommandations
donc évidemment ça a été le jackpot pour
les producteurs de bacon est l'un des
premiers succès industriel d'edward
bernays
le troisième fait d'armes de barneys
c'est l'un des plus connus car en même
temps l'un des plus spectaculaires dans
les années 20 donna is a été mandatée
par la firme de tabac lucky strike afin
d'augmenter ses ventes
et c'est là qu'il a mis au point une
stratégie aussi perfide qu'efficace qui
consistait à persuader les femmes de se
mettre à fumer à l'époque les fumoirs
étaient encore réservés aux hommes et
les seules femmes qui fumaient été
essentiellement les prostituées donc la
stratégie de bernay c'était de modifier
la perception de modifier la
représentation de la cigarette chez les
femmes parce que bernès était
parfaitement conscient que nos actions
étaient d'abord lié à la manière dont on
se représenter symboliquement une
pratique il est évident que si une
pratique et stigmatise m si elle est
déconsidéré dans l'opinion il ya c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de l'assumer
dont café bernese ils organisaient une
manifestation lors du dimanche de pâques
à new york en 1929 une manifestation
composée de femmes deux femmes qui
étaient rémunérés pour défiler et qui
arborait une cigarette à la main ainsi
que des pancartes sur lesquelles il
était écrit torches de la liberté
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument crucial si on veut comprendre
la mécanique de la manipulation c'est
que le principe de la manipulation de
l'opinion
c'est d'accoler à une pratique une
représentation symbolique
c'est d'associer à un usage une
signification qui va permettre de
légitimer cet usage voire de le
promouvoir socialement
et donc à travers cette manifestation la
cigarette n'était plus vu comme un signe
de vulgarité elle était vue comme un
symbole de réappropriation du phallus
masculin
elle était vue comme un symbole de
conquête de l'émancipation
autrement dit il ne s'agissait pas
simplement de vanter les vertus de la
cigarette en tant que tel puisque à
l'époque dans les années 20 beaucoup de
médecins pensaient que la cigarette
avait des effets positifs sur la santé
notamment qu'elle permettait de diminuer
le stress mais la stratégie de bernès
n'a pas été de montrer que la cigarette
était bénéfique pour la santé
ça c'était presque trop facile c'était
de dire qu'une femme qui fumaient était
une femme qui se réapproprier sa liberté
une femme qui fumaient devenait une
révolutionnaire
et ça c'est beaucoup plus efficace c'est
beaucoup plus efficace parce qu'à ce
moment là on ne s'adresse plus
simplement à la raison on s'adresse aux
représentations inconsciente
on s'adresse aux symboles aux archétypes
et on substitue à la fonction de l'objet
sa représentation symbolique
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on voit
une femme qui fume on ne se dit pas que
ce qui en est à l'origine
c'est la stratégie de propagande de
bernès
on ne se dit pas que ce qui en est à
l'origine c'est une entreprise de
manipulation
on se dit que les femmes fument comme
les hommes fument et que c'est tout
simplement le signe d'une égalité
d'une égalité conquise de haute lutte
sauf que cette lutte était une mise en
scène
les seuls bénéficiaires de l'opération
ont été les firmes de tabac
gêné la manipulation des opinions c'est
de faire en sorte que l'opinion
personnelle fasse oublier le but initial
c'est de faire en sorte que notre
sensibilité
occulte les raisons objectives
de bernès n'a jamais été de libérer les
femmes de l'oppression masculine le but
de barneys
c'était d'augmenter les ventes de
l'industrie du tabac
et le cynisme de cette entreprise c'est
d'avoir transformé aux yeux de l'opinion
une stratégie de manipulation collective
en une conquête du progrès
manipulation des opinions c'est la
stratégie qui consiste à faire passer
pour un progrès objectif une
manipulation de nos consciences
individuelles
le principe de la manipulation de
l'opinion c'est de faire naître et de
consolider des représentations dans
notre conscience pour rendre les
individus complice et acteurs de leur
domination
la manipulation c'est le pouvoir - la
coercition
parce que la manipulation
elles gardent au chaud le sentiment de
liberté
sous l'effet d'une manipulation c'est
agir avec la croyance d'être libre c'est
agir par un élan spontané par un élan
intérieur
c'est agir sans se rendre compte que le
principe de notre action a été influencé
c'est agir avec la conviction d'être
libre
le tour de force de la propagande
idéologique moderne c'est d'avoir réduit
le concept de liberté au concept de
désir et d'avoir réduit le désirent à la
satisfaction pulsionnel
alors si vous êtes intéressés par cette
question question extrêmement importante
et d'actualité qui est la manipulation
de l'opinion par la manipulation de nos
désirs
ja je conseille vivement de lire les
livres de michel clouscard et notamment
le capitalisme de la séduction et néo
fascisme et idéologie du désir dans
lesquelles ils montrent parfaitement
comment après la seconde guerre mondiale
les anciens systèmes de contrôle
politique et de contrôle idéologique
qu'était l'état et la religion
ce qu'on pourrait appeler dès système
coercitif des systèmes autoritaires ont
été remplacés par des systèmes permissif
c'est à dire des systèmes qui allait
promouvoir l'individualité et le désir
et que c'est ainsi qu'on est passé d'un
ancien mode de domination par la
contrainte à un nouveau modèle de
domination par la liberté le désir et le
consentement
le marché du désir veut ça maxima
d'expansion par la massification du
libéralisme libertaire ce sera mai 68 un
fabuleux marché était virtuel industrie
du loisir du plaisir du divertissement
de la mode mais le consommateur
potentiel était encore inhibé par les
totem et tabou de la société
traditionaliste la morale interdit de
consommer ce que l'on n'a pas produit
alors que le capitalisme bancaire permet
de jouir sans avoir il fallait une
mutation globale dès mars mais conquis
ce autorisé et même légitimé par l'état
il fallait cohn-bendit et pompidou la
profonde complicité du libertaire
contestataires et du libéral éclairé et
débonnaire pour liquider le vieux et
rendre possible la nouvelle société
michel clouscard les métamorphoses de la
lutte des classes
c'est ce qui permet de voir que la
manipulation est beaucoup plus efficace
que n'importe quel autre technique basée
sur la contrainte et l'autorité
on peut le voir aujourd'hui avec
l'idéologie dû marché dont l'un des
ressorts principaux et la consommation
et la consommation fonctionne très
exactement sur ce principe du désir et
de la conversion du désir en acte
d'achat
n'importe quelle publicité n'importe
quel système de propagande pour une
marchandise pas aujourd'hui s'appuyer
sur cette mécanique du désir dans cette
mécanique de la représentation qui va
s'adresser directement à notre pulsion
et c'est cette sollicitation pulsionnel
ce recrutement du désir qui va agir
comme le plus puissant vecteur de la
consommation
de nos jours beaucoup de personnes
croient encore ne sait par l'autorité
que c'est par la contrainte que le
pouvoir économique s'exerce sur les
masses
c'est tout le contraire
le pouvoir économique n'a aucun intérêt
à recourir à la contrainte
quand c'est animé par la pulsion que
nous consommons le plus
le pouvoir économique fonctionne sur
l'incitation à la satisfaction du désir
il a tout intérêt à l'exhibition
pulsionnel
et non à l'inhibition
car dans l'acte d'achat aucune force
n'est supérieure à celle de la pulsion
et là ça va me donner l'occasion de
faire une précision conceptuel
extrêmement importante sur ce qu'on
appelle l'endoctrinement
la plupart du temps l'endoctrinement est
vu comme une entreprise de conversion de
la pensée basé sur le refoulement basée
sur la répression du désir
et l'exemple qui est le plus souvent
utilisé c'est celui des religions
et religions dont on sait qu'elles sont
extrêmement sévères envers le désir
extrêmement prohibit rice
la religion nous enjoint à nous méfier
nos désirs à nous éloigner des plaisirs
de la chair et à nous tourner vers une
vie spirituelle une vie dédiée à dieu
qui doit être exempte de toute trace de
pêcher de toute trace de concupiscence
il n'y a qu'à faire un tour rapide des
sept péchés capitaux pour se rendre
compte à quel point le désir et le
plaisir terrestres sont condamnés
la gourmandise l'envi
la luxure
la paresse
sont liées à la manifestation des désirs
du corps
on retrouve beaucoup cette idée dans de
nombreuses religions monothéistes que le
corps ait quelque chose d'un pur et que
les impulsions du corps doivent être
combattus on n'accède pas à la
sanctification par la satisfaction
pulsionnel
on accède à la sanctification par
l'éloignement vis-à-vis des impulsions
du corps
par la neutralisation de notre dimension
pulsionnel
donc les religions constitue des
systèmes d'endoctrinement répressif
c'est à dire reposant sur l'obéissance à
des lois tandis que l'idéologie du désir
constituer un système d'endoctrinement
permissif
c'est à dire reposant sur l'obéissance à
nos pulsions
on retrouve là encore l'opposition
freudienne entre le surmoi et le ca le
surmoi c'est l'instance législatrice
c'est l'autorité
moi c'est ce qui nous dit tu dois et tu
ne dois pas
c'est le représentant de la loi en nous
alors que le ca
c'est le torrent du désir c'est le chaos
pulsionnel
le saint c'est cette énergie qui nous
pousse à la satisfaction personnelle et
qui réclame l'intervention du surmoi qui
réclame le contrôle et la régulation par
l'autorité
bien partir du moment où l'individu est
régie par le ca à partir du moment où il
est gouverné par sa dimension pulsionnel
le meilleur moyen de le contrôler le
meilleur moyen de le dominer et de
l'influencé dans ses actions c'est de
prendre le contrôle de sa pulsion
c'est de prendre le contrôle de son
désir
dictature sont basés sur l'obéissance à
la loi l'obéissance aux sur moi d'où
d'ailleurs le culte de la personnalité
qui existent bien souvent la
personnalité étant celle du chef
le mot chef signifiant étymologiquement
la tête dictature basé sur l'obéissance
à la loi
quand les démocraties sont basés sur
l'obéissance aux désirs
ce qui structure la manipulation des
opinions démocratie ce n'est pas la
prohibition pulsionnel c'est la
désinhibition pulsionnel
c'est l'incitation à la jouissance
un peuple qui jouit c'est un peuple qui
se tient tranquille
c'est un peuple qui veut juste continuer
à jouir
même si sa jouissance est assez peu
satisfaisante
cité où les besoins physiologiques sont
remplies dans une société où les frigos
sont pleins
le besoin de jouir se substitue au
besoin de se nourrir
et parfois même le surpasse
certains croient encore que le désir est
quelque chose de tabou dans nos sociétés
le désir n'est pas tabou
le désir est un totem
désir est un objet de culte et réfréner
ses désirs ne pas y obéir
c'est bien souvent vue comme la marque
d'un comportement soumis là où
satisfaire ses désirs serait la marque
de l'émancipation
et donc c'est au prix de ce renversement
de la hiérarchie des valeurs entre
l'inhibition pulsionnel et la
désinhibition pulsionnel que la
propagande peut tirer profit de la
liberté des individus
laissez un individu libre il obéira de
lui-même à son désir
pour influencer l'opinion il ne faut pas
s'adresser à sa partie rationnelle
il faut s'adresser à sa partie
émotionnelle
et ainsi le rendre aveugle à ses
intérêts objectifs
alors en vrac quelques techniques pour
influencer l'opinion première technique
jouer sur les peurs parce que la peur
permettra l'acceptation de mesures
restrictives à l'égard des libertés
individuelles
ne faut surtout pas sous-estimer le
besoin de sécurité car en situation de
danger
le besoin de sécurité l'emportent sur le
besoin de liberté
comme je le suggérais précédemment la
liberté et la libre satisfaction
pulsionnel ne peut naître que dans un
contexte où les besoins physiologiques
sont déjà satisfaits
dans l'ordre des priorités le besoin de
sécurité et placé avant le besoin
liberté
et jouer sur les peurs est encore le
meilleur moyen de tenir un peuple en
respect
deuxième technique créé des clivages
alors ça c'est un petit peu une loi du
genre sur la question des débats
politiques c'est à dire se positionner
pour ou contre
sans possibilité de nuancer ou de
proposer une position d'équilibré dans
le cas par exemple d'une intervention
militaire est ce qu on est pour
est-ce qu'on est contre
dans le cas d'une proposition de loi est
ce qu on est pour est-ce qu'on est
contre
c'est donc ce principe de la binarité
qui peut très vite dérivé en manichéisme
et qui fait qu'on laisse aucune place à
la pensée la panse étant par définition
subtil et donc on va se positionner pour
faire prévaloir notre appartenance à un
camp parce qu appartenir à un camp c'est
pouvoir se considérer et se définir
comme membres d'un groupe
ça correspond donc au besoin
d'appartenance
troisième technique posé un sujet en
terme d'affrontements des valeurs alors
ça c'est une technique que j'aime
beaucoup
justement parce qu'elle permet de
constater à quel point nous sommes tous
impliqués dans ce processus de la
domination par les émotions
et pour vous le montrer je vais prendre
un exemple volontairement polémique
justement pour vous montrer à quel point
nous sommes domestique et à réagir par
l'émotion
à quel point nous sommes adressés à
abandonner notre capacité d' examen
rationnel
dès lors que nous avons un intérêt
émotionnel à nous positionner
cet exemple c'est celui de la gestation
pour autrui
la gestation pour autrui c'est une
pratique qui consiste à faire porter un
enfant à une autre femme que la donneuse
d'ovocytes
va donc y avoir une mère porteuse et une
mère intentionnelle
la mère intentionnelle étant celle à qui
va appartenir l'enfant
mais petit détail qui a son importance
c'est que la mère porteuse porte un
enfant en échange d'une rémunération
et c'est ce qui fait que la gpa suscite
de très nombreux débats à
l'international et chacun généralement
une position sur le sujet
du point de vue idéologique du point de
vue des valeurs il est possible de
défendre la gpa au nom de l'égalité des
droits
voire au nom du progrès or et qui
consiste à pallier l'infertilité
c'est à dire au nom d'un progrès conçu
comme émancipation vis-à-vis des
contraintes naturelles
maintenant si on envisage la question
sous l'angle économique est bien la gpa
c'est la mise en place d'une économie de
la naissance c'est la mise en place
d'une marchandisation de la vie avec des
couples qui peuvent payer des femmes
pour porter leurs enfants et des femmes
porteuses en situation de détresse
économique
et donc si demain un gouvernement
démocratique voulait faire passer une
loi autorisant la gpa sous quel angle
croyez-vous qu'il présentera les choses
est ce qui les présentera sous l'angle
de la marchandisation hausse qui les
présentera sous l'angle du droit à
l'égalité
voilà vous avez de dire ouais mais c'est
trop gros
c'est trop visible utiliser le joker
idéologique de l'égalité des droits
ça ne pourra pas passer
parce que ça entre eux rétro en
contradiction avec nos valeurs
d'indisponibilité du corps humain
le fait que la vie humaine ne peut pas
faire l'objet d'une marchandisation
très bien
mais la guerre en irak au nom des droits
de l'homme
hier en syrie au nom de la démocratie
quand on sait qu'une intervention
militaire implique le contrôle des
ressources et la gestion des
infrastructures par exemple des gazoducs
est-ce que ce n'était pas trop gros
est-ce que ce n'était pas trop visible
et pourtant
au nom de quoi at-on justifié ses
interventions au nom de quoi at-on
persuader l'opinion publique de
consentir à ses interventions
au nom de quoi
la photo de cet enfant mort sur une
plage de turquie alan curdy
ils photo qui a fait le tour du monde et
des réseaux sociaux
à quoi a servi cette photo
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas servi à faire
s'émouvoir l'opinion
naître en toute personne ayant une âme
un sentiment d'indignation
qu'est-ce qui est atroce dans cette
image
de dire qu'elle a été utilisée pour
manipuler l'opinion
ou le fait qu'elle ait effectivement été
utilisés pour manipuler l'opinion
l'opinion est une émanation de ce que
d'abord rappelé la société du spectacle
la société du spectacle c'est la société
de la mise en scène généralisée
et de l'exhibition émotionnel
objectif c'est de nous rendre consentant
à ce que nous refuserions
catégoriquement
si on nous annonce est clairement la
couleur
c'est de nous rendre consentant à ce
qu'il nous serait impossible d'accepter
si on ne nous le présentait pas sous un
angle émotionnel
nos démocraties sont devenues le théâtre
de ce spectacle
le spectacle du progrès spectacle de la
liberté spectacle de l'égalité spectacle
comment c'est ce que l'on montre
est ce que l'on montre c'est ce qu'il y
a un intérêt à montrer
un intérêt à montrer le défilé des
femmes new yorkaise arborant fièrement
les torches de la liberté
il ya un intérêt à montrer un enfant
mort en pleine crise diplomatique et
militaire
il ya un intérêt à montrer de ce qui
peut produire un choc dans la conscience
ce qui peut émouvoir et avoir une
influence sur nos opinions
manipuler nos opinions
manipuler notre parti innocente
la partie qui ne raisonnent pas
un parti qui ne vois pas où est le mal
nos émotions c'est manipuler nos
faiblesses
nous détestons reconnaître que l'on
abusé de nos faiblesses
on préfère se dire que nos faiblesses ne
sont pas
on préfère se dire que nos émotions que
notre sensibilité sont la marque de
notre humanité
notre amour du prochain
mais une manière
ce conflit entre émotions les raisons
de se dire que nous avons droit
d'éprouver des émotions
nous avons droit d'être sensible
également de ne pas réserver nos
émotions au spectacle
de ne pas réserver nos émotions à la
scène médiatique de la manipulation
manipulation par l'émotion ce n'est pas
dénoncé l' émotion
c'est dénoncer l'instrumentalisation de
l'émotion
dénoncer
la prise en otage de nos consciences
c'est les chaînes invisibles qui nous
empêche d'exercer notre discernement
qui nous empêche d'exercer
qui aussi
notre humanité notre raison je vous
remercie
[Musique]